eric you have that chris can you hear me
yeah
yeah okay uh curtis um
what what happened with the offense and
what do you think was
was the cause of the offense kind of
stopping up in those last seven minutes
or so i think you all got
a three from lou and a three from shea
but other than that
um y'all didn't score in the last seven
minutes i know that that's that's on me
you know i mean we was pushing the pace
really good then we just got stagnant
i think the most frustrating part is uh
that last play i put shea in a tough
situation
i gotta find a way to get us a better
shot
we have been playing with pace sort of
uh
seeking out robert covington and
um i don't know it's a tough one we had
our chances
nigallo okc thunder.com
chris uh you guys have been in the
bubble now for for 57 days
if you have uh i probably haven't
thought about it much yet but just the
perspective on what you guys
accomplished as a team what you guys
accomplished as players down there in
your time
oh man it's a tough one
we we fought hard all year
um obviously a lot of people doubters
but we didn't doubt ourselves
uh we didn't give a damn about anybody's
predictions going into any series
in any game we we expected to win
all right and that's the way we played
all season long every game we expected
to win
and so uh
hey chris we know how much you've uh
worked with those young guys
specifically lou and shay
um to see and darius too to see those
three guys play like they did tonight
what did that mean for you and for this
team
they deserve to win and they did
everything they were supposed to do
i had a floater right there in the
middle of the lane that would put us at
once so uh
it's tough because all that's all i said
let's just
keep it close and we'll finish it and
that's that's on me so i couldn't have
nothing else from from from them guys
very trammel with the oklahoman
yeah chris i know it's tough on a loss
but
when you think about what lou dort did
two games ago
and then what he did tonight offensively
have you seen
have you seen a game like that from an
undrafted free agent
who all of a sudden leading scorer
goes for 30 in a game seven it was
special um
they were helping off and we all just
kept making the right plays and we knew
that
we had our confidence in him so uh
we expected that from lou and
you're gonna be in this league for a
long time
all right last one for you chris we're
gonna go to uh daniel bell with black
sports online
hey chris um on the free throw to
bring it down to one what it went into
uh
gallo taking it instead of you you watch
any of the games we didn't play gallow
always shoot the text
it happened again we do the same thing
so don't
yeah i had the utmost confidence in
gallup so
if we had it over again he shoot it
again
thank you chris got a couple in the room
john we've got taylor rooks please
report go ahead
hey chris there was a lot happening with
the officiating tonight
there was a delay of game paul why do
you feel like you've got that fall
game uh
it's crazy this has been going on in the
bubble like the replays
they show the replays sometimes so that
obviously it's an advantage if you get
to see the replay and then you challenge
so like myself and i dropped down the
top of my shoe
to hopefully see if we see the replay
scott foster walked over to me and told
me
chris you ain't got to do that i got him
sweeping up the floor
okay cool so i started tying my shoe
back up
and he still caught the leg down
that [ __ ] don't make no sense but
i don't know that's crazy he just
i don't know we could have won the game
but that situation
league note right
yeah they gonna find me i said his name
yeah we already know the history it's
all bad
so much has happened since we've been
here in the bubble so as the journey
comes to a hand we're just asking
players to give their last words just to
recap everything
nice words
i get to see my kids and my family
thank you chris thank you so much that
you've been able to make
[Music]
um
he made a point to tell me that he
wrapped himself up
you